can we talk about nancy pelosi for a
second
so she's running for re-election nancy
pelosi has announced he's running for
re-election oh good for her
is she just doing this because it looks
like the demo the 2029 democrats are
resigning 20 20 you mean you mean the 29
democrats are resigning yeah and 29
democrats are about to resign so that
she's like well we're going to lose the
entire house to the republicans so i
need to stay here is that you think
that's why she's yeah i mean she can
retire at any time or end her campaign
at any time so you know you know what i
think we should do and uh and hear me
out okay 100 serious hearing i believe
some uh nice gentleman should bring in a
wheelchair to her office place her in it
put a blanket on her lap and wheel her
out
bring her to a home and make sure she's
comfortable
and then we the people will decide what
to do next
are you suggesting she has a joe biden
problem
nancy pelosi yeah i mean she's she's
just old and out of touch and
incompetent and at a certain point we
have we have an age minimum but perhaps
we require an age limit as well she
shakes when she talks well we were
talking about fallout i mean we're
talking about this uh before before the
show started you know compare and
contrast the mental
of dr
who's 81 exactly joe biden and or nancy
pelosi or many others
to be fair fauci has flip-flopped so
often maybe he does have
some kind of brain thing
i mean it's true it's so much more about
the individual person it's very you
can't really put in a blanket statement
saying at this age the person has to
step down because some people are just
sharp at an older race the nice thing
about comparing biden then why do we
have an age minimum minimum no i mean i
well i think the age minimum is a life
experience thing i think that's a big
part of it i mean do you want like a 21
year old in any of these positions yo if
there's somebody who started working
in you know like a factory with like
their family or whatever when they were
seven
and they've got 15 years of experience
in
you know a political and an industrial
environment
it's better than a 25 year old who just
graduated from college what about
non-americans i hear what you're saying
what do you mean like elon
a non-american that moves to the united
states when they're two but they can't
be president and they have all these
restrictions on what they can be in
government do you think that we should
get rid of that stuff no i think that's
good yeah but age restrictions you think
we should get rid of age restrictions no
i'm i'm in favor of putting more on oh i
think you said a young genius should
have i said we should have an age limit
for old people and he said but no you
can't determine the life experience you
know yeah blah some people and then i
said well for we do it for young people
my point is we have a we have a minimum
we should have a maximum i'm not saying
definitively i completely 100 believe we
should have a maximum i'm saying let's
entertain the possibility that someone
who's 80 should probably retire you
could do cognitive tests but this is so
the laws they are passing they will not
live underneath
okay so
you know if a society grows great when
when people plant trees whose shade they
know they will never sit beneath 80 year
olds like pelosi and old people like
biden are not planting trees for anyone
yeah they're they're they're not going
to see whatever happens they don't care
it's a complicated
go ahead sorry well it's just it's a
complicated thing because
i do think that it's it's an age floor
is a a bit different from an aged
ceiling here but
ultimately we have a system that's
structured so that like because you
leave office eventually everyone's sort
of incentivized to just pull what they
can out of the system for as long as
they can until they leave without really
thinking about the long-term
consequences because let's say you have
a young
politician and sure it's like they're
not going to have to live under the
policies anyway because there are
different laws for them they're above it
well so my proposal was the island
the island which is as soon as you leave
office you get sent to an island
where you will live with other people
who have left office you will you will
not you will own nothing and you'll be
happy
i have an island where i put people but
would do different categories
a flying island i don't know maybe they
can go along with them uh i don't
seriously think you know that idea
is the right idea but i i'm just trying
to think like how do you stop someone
from saying i'm gonna run for office i'm
gonna get in i'm gonna extract as much
as i can and then i'm gonna run away you
don't that's all any of them do well i
mean how do you stop it i don't know it
might be built into democracy and
representative
i i
this is advice as head of judicial watch
we're nonpartisan i give to all
politicians
to me running on a reform agenda
would be a solution there and that
agenda would include term limits
balanced budget amendments significant
cuts to the federal government
because what happens is it's not someone
who's 80 it's someone who's 80 who got
there when they were 40.
you know i prefer having someone there
75 to 85 there for 10 years you know
that experience
is of great value to society so that's
not the issue the issue is
the term of office that politicians are
in and to me you know i know there are a
lot of conservatives who don't like the
idea of term limits i don't think it's a
silver bullet but what happens is it
breeds the worst aspects of being a
politician you're right
cynicism
institutionalism contempt for other
people's views who aren't in congress
because you've known it all since you've
been there forever no no no we need new
blood every every few years you're right
and
i think i i will revise my the island
statement and just say perhaps solution
is logan's run
great movie yeah sheamus are you
familiar i have i have not seen logan's
right so when you turn watching when you
turn 30 you uh
you know you get you shuffle off the
mortal coil are you so people have life
spoiling it people have lights yeah
that's what i mean
we laugh but that's been the approach
with why briar could die in office
you know that's why they were angry at
uh what's ruth bader ginsburg that's how
she died during the trump administration
she should have gotten out that's a
great uh uh
uh satirical article red light on
briar's hand begins blinking red yeah
that's forced to retire that's the way
the left looks at supreme court justices
in logan's run they had lights on their
hands and it was like when they were
young it was green when they're getting
old turns yellow and they when they're
about to turn 30 it starts blinking red
and then logan's run is you know he runs
yeah he's like i don't want to die
almost he just rides he's like
they kind of did so there was a film i
saw a few years ago it was like i saw it
recently but it came out about 10 years
ago it's with justin timberlake it's not
exactly the same but you have like you
have a bar code on your arm that says
the amount of time that you're alive for
when it counts down to zero and you can
buy time but you can buy time yeah so
wealth is the amount of time you have so
it's like not exactly the same but kind
of a different twist on it yeah that
one's i think i saw that i think that's
a cool concept yeah so maybe maybe uh we
i don't know it's weird these these
sci-fi dystopian movies aren't really
the same
it would have to be in a dream like they
trap you in your metaverse and then you
have to run in the dream because then
because in the real life if you try and
run there's drone bombs and like blazes
but in the dream you can run away no no
ian you run for office
and you can run to get away from office
you get like
so a term is four years you run for
congress boom here for four years as
soon as that four uses up there's no
re-election you get locked in the matrix
wow that's it you're just out we don't
have the technology so it's just gonna
be mark zuckerberg like duct taping
oculus to your forehead and putting you
in the metaverse like you can't get out
covered up sources yeah the theory is
there was an old the old play dr marlowe
by uh well no faustus by christopher
marlowe uh he's dr faustus yeah faustus
is dealing with the devil mephistopheles
and he said how did you get out of hell
mephistopheles he said this is hell nor
am i out of it so
we're still in the matrix yeah man
you know maybe maybe i think the
metaverse is coming i think we're all
going to get locked inside of it we're
in a matrix you can measure the matrix
we're in if you know how much of
something what it is and where it is and
you can measure that in the xyz axis
this cube that we're within okay i have
no idea what that means yeah my
microphone check define them yeah spot
check defined
my proposal is uh is this
when we elect joe rogan as president in
2028 he should issue an executive order
mandating dmt passport requirements for
access to bars restaurants and
universities ideally did
i think that joe rogan's credit i don't
think joe rogan would vote for joe rogan
no i agree good point i love the
humility that's true but it would be
funny joe is it's his guests they talk a
lot about joe rogan and he is a genius
like he'll talk himself down but the way
he can sit there and listen to jordan
peterson you need a genius he's the
larry king of the internet age yeah and
shout out to his guests i mean there is
there is something to be said about a
passport for some kind of deeper
understanding of reality i don't think
it's necessarily you know dmt that's the
joke but
perhaps if we society where like
you know uh service guarantees
citizenship or something that affect you
know
like you need to understand something
you need to do work and contribute for
something in order to to get something
in return right now it's it's you know
we had that famous quote
ask not what your country can do for you
but what you can do for your country
it's completely inverted these days yeah
yeah well there's a war on citizenship i
mean the whole the whole zeitgeist now
is to eliminate the distinctions between
citizens and non-citizens oh new york's
yeah so so
i mean they want you to be it's
offensive to the transnational
progressives they don't believe in
nation states and sovereignty because it
gets in the way
of the communist utopia they're pushing
yeah you know and i wouldn't have said
this six years i mean you know you knew
this this was out there among the
marxists for a long time but now there's
kind of a rising communism in a major
party here in the country
that that this is this is this is their
go-to strategy it's not coincidence i
mean when crt is the guiding movement
narrative for a presidential
administration
you know those those pushing it must be
very proud dude build back better is a
klaus schwab thing now to correct me if
i'm wrong but this is part of the world
economic forum's great reset is build
back better this is where i first heard
of it and then all of a sudden a year
later joe biden is saying those words as
if we're gonna do it without referencing
klaus schwab and please correct me if
i'm wrong if klaus schwab didn't say it
then i'm totally off base but i remember
talking it was all over europe i think
boris johnson claimed uh biden stole it
from him
because belback batter was all over
europe okay well nancy pelosi uh used
drain the swamp when she ran for off ran
for the republic ran to take control of
congress in 2010. wow there's nothing
new under the sun yep and make america
great again was ronald reagan yeah
morning in america yeah morning america
this is exactly right klaus schwab is
first started circulating the idea of
the great reset which uses build back
better integral parts so we are we're
lost are we allowed to say the right
reset yeah great reset is very very
plain i know all these algorithms get
triggered by certain words it's either
directly influenced and has co-opted our
president or indirectly but this
methodology of building back better with
a socialized corporate
political government state is in joe
biden's head whether he realizes it or
not well certainly wikovit you know
initially there was this panicked crazed
decision making on the shutdowns now
it's vindictive and vicious
and they see it as an opportunity for
dramatic political and social change
i mean i i don't think it's any mistake
you had this reddit thing pop up with i
don't want to work yeah after two years
of people not having to work yeah thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8 00 pm
and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you